[Musique]
Argentine France États-Unis
sur les cinq continents casqués de
fleurs warmée de pavés les libertaires
sont lentement sorties de la nuit et ont
allumé des feux de joie eux que l'on
avait cruc ils ont partout repris
l'initiative participer à de vaches nos
mouvements insurrectionnel et prix
davantage dans la bataille pour
l'hégémonie culturelles mais gagner des
batailles n'est rien pour si l'on ne
gagne pas la guerre sociale or dans les
années qui suivent 1968 les anarchistes
vont découvrir un nouveau péril non plus
celui de disparaître mais celui de ce
fourvoyer car face à un système
globalité qui met en scène les
apparences de sa propre critique leur
stockage émancipateur leur rifle
assassins et même leur figures ont
parfois fini paraître récupéré pour
faire avancer leurs idées les
libertaires ne vont plus dès lors avoir
d'autres choix du local à
l'international que d'avancer masquée et
par la guérilla ou dans la mobilisation
de masse en revenir à la propagande et
c'est ainsi que des faubourgs
va souvent inspirer sans aujourd'hui son
nom les nouvelles formes de résistance
et dans cette poche de modernité qui se
voulait la fin des temps relancer pour
un tour au moins la grande roue de notre
histoire
que l'année 68 était une répétition
générale ou une révolution manquée il
n'en reste pas moins qu'elle aura laissé
comme un goût d'inachevé sur la langue
des révolutionnaires
comment ne pas comprendre que le nombre
d'entre eux soit déçus devant le
spectacle des populations reprenant le
travail mais face au retour des éternels
polémiques entre organisation qui se
rejettent la faute et entend le ramasser
des mises pourquoi ne serait-il pas
adorer que ré que faire
alors que certains décident de prendre
la clé des champs et rejoignent à la
campagne des communautés d'autres soient
par optimisme soit par désespoir
choisissent rester dans les villes afin
d'essayer par un coup de force de
précipiter les choses
[Musique]
pour les anarchistes tout commence en
réalité en Uruguay en 1965 quand Abraham
Ghislaine ancien combattant au sein
d'une division anarchiste en Espagne
mais aussi diplômée en sciences aux
économiques qui a participé à toutes les
tentatives d'insurrectionnelles de
l'après-guerre publie son livre
stratégie du guérilla urbaine pour
comprendre la nouveauté de son ouvrage
il faut se souvenir que depuis le
triomphe de la révolution cubaine en
matière de lutte armée c'est la théorie
de Che Guevara dite du Focus qui
recueille toutes les faveurs des
révolutionnaires les guerriers-aux
doivent partir dans les montagnes et
dans la jungle pour créer au côté des
paysans et des indigènes des foyers
insurrectionnels
cette théorie qui a pu montrer son
efficacité dans le contexte cubain doit
à tout prix selon Abraham Ghislaine être
repensé pour les pays plus développés
dans une guerre révolutionnaire quand
les masses urbaines sont plus
importantes que les masses rurales le
centre de gravité de la lutte doit se
situer dans les airs urbaines les
grandes cités sont des forêts immenses
de Simon ou tous les artifices de la
guerre de guérilla peuvent être
correctement employés l'heure est venue
ou une minorité révolutionnaire peut
mettre la masse en mouvement et
permettre de surmonter l'aliénation par
la peur
théorie de la guérilla urbaine et de la
propagande armée vient de naître et
Abraham Guilaine de préciser
l'objectif selon moi c'est la prise de
conscience
la prise de conscience que le système
capitaliste est fragile
et que les prolétaires peuvent donc
mener eux-mêmes la lutherme
entre parenthèses c'est la vision
classique des attentats anarchistes
depuis la fin du 19e siècle la
propagande par le fait
la théorie d'Abraham dylaine se diffuse
rapidement en Uruguay où la révolte
gronde depuis qu'en ce milieu des années
60 s'évite une crise économique profonde
elle inspire notamment un groupe de
jeunes révolutionnaires les toupas Maroc
emmené par House and beach un partisan
de l'autogestion fin connaisseur de
Proudhon et rassemblez autour de mon
ordre libertaire on retrouve parmi eux
des socialistes révolutionnaires des
communistes hétérodogues des prêtres
influencés par la théologie de la
libération mais aussi depuis l'origine à
l'image de Gérard dogatti Georges
savalsa et Rosset mourica de très
nombreux libertaires les anarchistes
participent à la formation des
toupamaros
sont d'ailleurs un respect de la vie
humaine
en ce sens c'est une lutte très
respectable
les toupas Maroc s'adopte aussitôt la
stratégie de la guérilla urbaine et de
la propagande l'armée ils attaquent tous
les immunités enchaînent les coups
d'éclat
[Musique]
pas un jour sans que leurs actions le
fassent les gros titres des journaux
lundi et tu pas marrant s'occupe une
usine
mardi hold-up 5 millions de pesos
mercredi attentat à la bombe dans
plusieurs clubs politiques jeudi
occupation d'une usine est bonze
vendredi bombe et hold-up samedi
dynamitage d'une chaîne de télévision et
dimanche en guise de repos évasion de
dizaines de détenus
le pouvoir a brûlénoncé lors de lance
les toupas Maroc qui dans un premier
temps évite le verset le sang sont bien
perçus par la presse et l'opinion
publique il bénéficie même sur la scène
internationale d'une image très positive
comme le prouve l'article que l'on
consacre alors le Time Magazine qui les
apparente à des Robins des voix des
temps modernes grâce à eux la théorie de
la guérilla urbaine et de la propagande
armée et celle dans le monde
les gens apprennent en répliquant quand
vous voyez un groupe qui fait des choses
que vous avez des connexions avec ce
groupe des réseaux secrets et alors on
retrouve un peu partout le même type
d'action c'est vraiment ce qui s'est
passé avec les hungry brigade par
exemple
partie d'Amérique latine la question de
la lutte armée se pose en effet à partir
de 1969 à tous les révolutionnaires
surtout on publie des jours en or on
fait des films on écrit des livres qui
parlent d'elle et des appels aux armes
sont lancés à la télévision
dans tous les quartiers sur nos lieux de
travail nous devons préparer dès
maintenant la lutte armée pour la
destruction de tous les capitalistes
aujourd'hui on se rappelle surtout des
Brigades rouges en Italie et de la
Fraction Armée Rouge en Allemagne qui
comme leur nom l'indique ne sont pas
anarchistes mais à l'époque comme
souvent ce sont les libertaires qui
prennent l'initiative comme un symbole
il y a des tout amaros ouest berline
avec Michael bombe qui sont les premiers
à faire trembler le vieux monde en
Espagne le groupe primaire des maillots
plus les commandos autonomes anti
capitalistes font parler la poutre
les appels à construire la guérilla sont
entendues en France aussi ou dès l'année
1970 le groupe révolutionnaire numéro 2
organise à Grenoble une semaine de la
dynamite suivie par les galeries qui
passent eux aussi à la tête
ils enchaînent les hold-up et multiplie
les attentats et les sabotages dans tout
le pays
même aux États-Unis d'Amérique d'anciens
hippies prennent les armes le
wasalanderground qui a la mémoire langue
fait par exemple sauter la statue des
policiers de la Market Square à Chicago
mais ce sont toutes au Royaume-Uni que
la stratégie de la propagande armée
anarchiste et menée de la manière la
plus emblématique par la hungry brigade
la brigade de la colère une organisation
qui a encore aujourd'hui n'a pas révélé
tous ces mystères de nombreuses
questions demeure que les journaux comme
Le time et d'autres se posent déjà à
l'époque tellement qui sont les Hongrie
brigade ça peut être n'importe qui
et la Hongrie brigade c'est cette
personne qui est assise à côté de toi
dans le métro et qui a de la haine plein
la tête et un revolver dans son blouson
n'importe qui peut être de la non ne
comptent pas
ce qui est très intéressant et qu'on a
aujourd'hui oublié avec des membres de
la soi-disant en gris brigade c'est
qu'ils étaient aussi impliqués dans
beaucoup d'activités d'entraide entre
communautés avec les syndicats
mais ils ont été décrits par la presse
de l'époque comme une horde de
terroriste punch c'est en réalité très
loin de ce qu'ils étaient
Rocky n'en est pas moins fortement
mobilisé politiqueé décider à passer à
la lutte armée ils adoptent ce nom de
brigade de la colère il s'invente un
logo où l'on voit les signes masculins
et féminins sans relacés autour d'une
galachnikov
car l'image des autres groupes de luth
armées de l'époque ce qui déroule alors
les observateurs c'est que parmi ces
combattants on compte de nombreuses
combattants dans la lignée des
Pétroleuses de la commune ces femmes
auxquelles on attribue le surnom
d'Amazon de la terreur effraie au temps
qu'elle fascine on se souvient notamment
en Allemagne de l'Ouest de l'intrépide
nada du mouvement du 2 juin et d'où le
ricamment Hof de la Fraction Armée rouge
qui bien que l'ayant rien d'anarchiste
étaient désignés comme tel dans les
tracts nous mettons cette étape prix
mais pour le public britannique c'est la
figure d'Anna Mendelson que l'on
soupçonne devrait au sein de la hungry
Guy qui synthétise tous les fantasmes et
retient l'attention dans cette interview
télévisée où elle résume d'un mot le
sens de son combat
sensible à toutes les formes de
domination et convaincue que la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaque
pendant près de trois ans les femmes et
les hommes de la hungry brigade font
converger les lutter en chaîne les
freins
celles-ci le bien sûr les banques les
sièges des grandes entreprises les
ambassades et les centres d'intérêts des
dictatures ils élargissent aussi le
périmètre des actions de la propagande
armée et lui ouvre ainsi de nouveaux
front
[Musique]
certaines de leurs cibles étaient assez
inhabituelles par exemple ils ont fait
exploser une boutique de mode Biba il
disait que Biba était un symbole de la
société de consommation et qu'à ce titre
elle devait être brûlée
bien se faire comprendre les actions
symboliques de la hungry bregade son
systématiquement accompagnés de
communiquer les explicatifs
frères et sœurs quels sont vos désirs
réels aller au drugstore pour vous
asseoir avec l'air distance vide ennuyé
en buvant un café sans goût ou bien
alors le faire sauter ou le faire brûler
la seule chose que vous puissiez faire
avec ces maisons d'esclavage moderne
appelé boutique c'est les démolir le
capitalisme le profit l'inhumanité ne se
réforme pas il faut les frapper jusqu'à
les détruire révolution
c'est de s'adresser à un public qui va
comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
vous menez vos actions mais le risque
évidemment c'est que vous allez aussi
laisser de côté tous ceux qui ne
ressentent pas de colère et ne peuvent
pas comprendre la symbolique de vos
actions
appartenant à d'autres tendances
révolutionnaires comme les Brigades
Rouges la Fraction Armée Rouge ou plus
tard action qui ont pu pratiquer des
exécutions et alors même qu'il frappe
jusqu'au porte du pouvoir avec une
campagne de lettres piégée envoyée au
journaux conservateurs au grand
industriels et aux ministres afin de ne
pas se couper de la population les
guerriers rejurbains de la hungry guyde
s'efforceront toujours de ne pas faire
couler le sang
ils n'ont jamais tué personne ils ont
fait quelques blessures mais pas très
sérieux
la Lucia
la propagande par le fait devait
toujours être symbolique et les Hongrie
brigade avait ce slogan très important
je crois
seuls les fascistes attaquent le peuple
et pourtant comme au 19e siècle la peur
s'empare des cercles dirigeants
on commence à déployer un formidable
Arsenal on vote des lois ancrées des
unités spéciales comme la bombe Squad au
Royaume-Uni et grâce à la toute nouvelle
informatique en mettant fiche des
populations en Europe et dans le monde
la chasse aux guerriers
urbains et données en Uruguay par
exemple le pouvoir se rigidifie et les
autorités multiplient les actions de
contraintes sur action
de filets sont lancés qui permettent
d'arrêter les figures du mouvement tout
par Marot comme ici Georges Saval ça
l'usage de la torture se généralise et
les escadrants de la mort sont lâchés
aux trousses tes révolutionnaires et
cette répression spectaculaire à elle
aussi les répliques et faites-elles en
revanche des victimes
en Allemagne de l'Ouest le combattant
anarchiste Georges van raar l'un des
fondateurs des tout-paro West Berlin et
le premier guerrier Roy urbain tué par
la police en Espagne malgré les
mobilisations internationales le
combattant libertaire Salvador putsch
antique est exécuté au Garo ville dans
la prison modelo de Barcelone et au
Royaume-Uni quelques prétendues membres
de la hungry brigade de One Direction
sont arrêtés on leur fait un procès le
plus long de l'histoire britannique et
bien qu'aucun ne soit reconnu coupable
pour les bons ou les lettres piégées on
en condamne certains à de très lourdes
peines de prison
les limites de l'action clandestine et
de la propagande armée sont atteints et
alors même que les anarchistes avaient
été les premiers à en faire l'apologie
se sentent aussi des libertaires qui
commencent à en faire très tôt la
critique
et son problème c'est un problème de ou
comment et pourquoi on fait un attentat
si c'est pour paralyser le capitalisme
ça peut valoir la peine
mais si c'est un attentat seulement
spectaculaire
pour qu'elle parce que la tentat suppose
une profonde inégalité entre ceux qui
ont la capacité et le savoir-faire des
bombes elle savait la terre et les gens
du commun ce qui vont au travail
tout ça il me semble donner une espèce
de
l'idéal héroïque guerrier
a des mouvements qui peut peut-être
remplacer le long travail un grade
d'organisation de formation de culture
il y a une certaine impatience
révolutionnaire qui fait que on imagine
qu'on va frapper l'ennemi au cœur en
mettant une bombinette ici ou là mais
qui a pleuré ont rarement réussi à
déclencher un quelconque social devant
les caméras quelques jours avant son
incarcération Anna mendelssen elle-même
admet la relativité de la seule
stratégie de l'attentat
[Musique]
nombreux sont le libertaire qui vont
alors préféré à la propagande armée la
propagande de tout court
à la fin des années 70 et au début des
années 80 après cette période de fortes
offensive révolutionnaire les
anarchistes reprennent donc leur bâtons
de pèlerins et tout en s'investissant
dans le mouvement punk qui éclôte alors
en ouvrant des maisons d'édition et des
librairies en créant des fanzines des
radios libres comme ici en France Radio
Libertaire ou en participant tout ça je
mensomobilisation ceci retourne pour
quelques années dans l'ombre
[Musique]
avec la chute du mur de Berlin et
l'effondrement de l'URSS le capitalisme
Trion il peut à loisir se globaliser et
entamer sa dernière mule
il renforce ses institutions et
généralise en offensive contre les corps
les cultures et les paysages le monde
devient un marché unique et global
auquel rien ne doit échapper et dans
lequel tout est désormais soumis à ses
lois des résidents ou alternatives
dit-on à ceux qui osent s'interroger
globales
Cloud
et cela a une influence sur l'anarchiste
qui s'inspire d'ailleurs de nombreux
mouvements indigènes
ils sont inspirés principalement par les
apathistes au Mexique
car c'est en 1994 que les apathis se
font connaître au monde
avec leur insurrection
1er janvier 1994 au crépuscule du matin
une armée anguille s'est levée
tout ça commence d'une manière très
intéressante moi
de la violence mais on ne peut pas dire
qu'il y ait vraiment de violence
que veulent-ils qui sont-ils ces
guerriereaux qui ne semblent pas
appartenir à la tradition libertaire
qui est plutôt de par une tradition on
va dire
marxiste voir gevariste
cela dit c'est une ordination
intelligente et qui a su prendre en
compte à la fois le milieu dans lequel
elle s'est développée donc à savoir le
tiapas qui est région fortement
indigènes et donc s'inspirer un petit
peu
de des pratiques des traditions de la
région et puis en même temps aller
rechercher aussi dans l'histoire du
Mexique donc c'est pour ça qu'ils se
rebondit aussi de deux appâts de ce
mouvement paysan avant
dit qu'aussi Ricardo flora's Magog comme
ce précurseur de la Révolution et en
même temps celui qui a amené le slogan
tiers à la libertad à l'autre bout de ce
pays où toutes les contradictions du
capitalisme se donne à voir alors que
près de la moitié de la population Vito
dessous du seuil de pauvreté ici le
Coca-Cola est devenu moins cher que
l'eau les économistes ont beau parler de
miracle mexicains les paysans indigènes
de l'armée apathiste délibération
nationale descendues des hauts plateaux
ou sorti de la jungle connaissent dans
leur chair les effets de la
globalisation néolibérale et de toutes
les formes de domination
ils occupent les centres de décisions
parce qu'il entend le plus être
dépossédé de leur terre de leur vie et
de leur tradition ils souhaitent
reprendre leurs affaires en main mais
ils ont beau écrire sur les murs leurs
programmes sur le moment les
commentateurs se désintéressent du
message et c'est sur le message que se
tourne alors tous les regards le sous
commandant marcors un ancien étudiant en
philosophie devenu Guerriero mais qui
sous l'influence des indiens à peu à peu
reconsidérer ces idées et ses stratégies
pour adopter une pensée plus libertaire
son grade qui n'existe dans aucune armée
du monde parce qu'au chat parce suivant
la forme mandat à rebelle esciento c'est
le peuple qui commande tout comme
l'usage du passe-montagnes témoignent de
cette évolution et pas sa montagne
oui ça répond évidemment aux problèmes
de la clandestinité
déclindres
mais en même temps tous portent le
passe-montagne
c'est à dire qu'ils sont tous à la fois
soldats et responsables
ce qui signifie pour eux nous sommes
tous frères et soeurs et nous
participons tous à la lutte
de la Lucia contre les États-Unis
apathiste dépasse des symboles et les
individualités elle réside dans
l'exemple qu'il donne d'un autre monde
possible
car l'expérience qui a commencé ici à la
suite de l'insurrection et s'étend sur
un territoire de la dimension d'un pays
mobilise plus de 250 000 personnes et
représentent l'une des plus longues et
des plus importantes expériences
l'auto-gouvernement collectif de
l'histoire moderne
société coopérative assemblée de femmes
conseils de bons gouvernement abolition
de l'argent et des prisons université
autonome hôpitaux gratuits sur cette
terre si isolé et si dur à la vie ces
hommes et ses femmes depuis toujours
humilier et méprisé ces forces dans les
faits de combiner pratique sans cesse
Strales et innovations politiques afin
de redessiner un monde à leur image
ils utilisent des formes d'organisation
anarchistes
de parole
pour coordonner les activités du groupe
mais elle ne fait que porter la parole
de ce groupe et ne prend pas de décision
à sa place
ce qu'ils veulent c'est une société dans
laquelle tout le monde aurait le même
pouvoir
l'anarchisme n'est pas une stratégie
antipouvoir
c'est une stratégie de contre-pouvoir
tu décentralisé et redistribuer le
pouvoir
c'est pour ça que je considère le
mouvement zapatiste
yodd comme appartenant la tradition
libertaire et anarchistes
mais eux de manière très saine à mon
avis se méfie et refuse les étiquettes
la geste des apathistes redonne espoir
révolutionnaire du monde qui se
coordonne au sein du jeune mouvement
altermondialiste et rien d'autre qui
passe pour participer aux assemblées
régionales aux conférences aux
internationales et jusqu'aux rencontres
intergalactiques organisées par le zlr
la grande réussite également du diapas
c'est d'avoir mis l'accent sur
l'international et la mondialisation et
donc permis à tout le monde de se
retrouver dans la lutte des indiens pour
peu que il on ne cloue pas le bec aux
Indiens on commence d'abord par les
écouter et ensuite les suivre et non pas
les précédés comme une avant-garde et
donc le mouvement
zapatiste a réussi à réussit son pari
effectivement de de fédérer tous les
mouvements Ré questionnaire a commencé
par les libertaires à cause de son
horizontalité
c'était un exemple d'une manière
différente de faire les choses depuis la
chute de l'Union soviétique que l'on
soit pour ou contre
les gens se cherchaient un nouveau
modèle
mais c'est exemple est considéré comme
une menace l'état envoie l'armée et les
propriétaires terriens leur milice qui
assassine au hasard comme par exemple
lors du massacre d'actéal ou 45
personnes sont exécutées parmi lesquels
18 enfants et quatre femmes enceintes
plutôt que d'encherrir dans la violence
leaden décide de marcher sur Mexico sans
arme afin de faire connaître son médecin
la stratégie apathiste
occupation Sécession auto-gestion vient
relancer des expériences déjà en cours
ou en inspiré de nouvelles un peu
partout dans le centre des empires
contre les grands projets inutiles et
leur monde comme un Lazare de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes
dans le berceau de la civilisation
occidentale comme un Athènes où le
quartier d'exercices s'insurgent contre
les politiques d'austérité ou aucun même
des combats comme rojava ou les Kurdes
prise en le tout entre les mercenaires
fanatisés de daesh et les armées
régulières du pouvoir autoritaire turc
font tout à la fois la guerre et la
révolution
car malgré leur diversité c'est luttes
se font bien au nom d'un même idéal
comme en témoigne le message de
solidarité que les combattants échangent
au plus fort les combats
[Musique]
mais au tournant du troisième millénaire
on sent que la réponse locale apportée
dans les pays du Sud est insuffisante et
c'est donc au nord que la globalisation
néolibérale va recevoir sa première
réponse globale
[Musique]
c'est bien sous l'oeil les caméras des
Chaînes d'infos en continu et au cœur de
la première puissance mondiale que le
troisième millénaire commence avec la
taxe d'un trade seulement pour
l'histoire de l'anarchisme ce n'est pas
celle de 2001 New York mais celle qui a
lieu deux ans auparavant de manière tout
aussi inattendue sur l'autre côte des
États-Unis d'Amérique je situerai pour
l'Amérique du Nord un point tournant
c'est la rencontre de seattles en 1999
la fameuse rencontre de seatto dans le
99 qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment-là moi-même inquiétait déjà
militant libertaire à l'époque je n'ai
pas vu venir
un expat de manière totalement
inattendue il y a eu cette énorme
manifestation à Seattle
contre le capitalisme international et
aussi contre l'OMC
qui a révélé soudain qu'une nouvelle
génération d'anarchiste était présente
et qu'elle organisait cette opposition à
l'OMC et à la Banque mondiale
[Musique]
novembre 1999 au pied du mont renier un
sommet de l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce doit avoir lieu qui entend rien
moins que définir les règles du prochain
millénaire déjà on savoure une nouvelle
avancée du capitalisme qui étendra son
entière marchand aux productions de
l'esprit haut vivant et à tous les
éléments le président de l'OMC et les
gouvernants les principales puissants
aux économiques n'ont pas choisi cette
au hasard ville natale de Bill Gates
alors l'homme le plus riche du monde la
cité d'émeraude est en effet la capitale
mondiale de l'aéronautique commerciale
et le centre planétaire du logiciel
informatique et l'accueille le siège
social de certaines des grandes
compagnies dont le nom rime déjà avec
globalisation et au libéral
mais c'était sans compter sur la
permanence ici d'une longue tradition
libertaire dont l'éclosion toute récente
du gringe une fusion entre le mouvement
Pink et le mouvement hippie avec Nirvana
en tête de gondole qui aimait à parsemer
ses clips de Acer n'étaient que la
dernière expression et sur le grand
appel international à la mobilisation
lancée par tout un agglomérat
d'organisation de collectif et
d'individus rassemblés au sein d'un
mouvement des mouvements qui a choisi de
profiter de cette occasion pour
manifester son opposition au Nouvel
Ordre Mondial
ès il n'y a pas de leader et c'est un
mouvement horizontal est d'action
directe contre les multinationales bref
il y a tous ces marqueurs
et si un grand nombre de personnes
impliquées ne se considéraient pas comme
anarchiste santé il y avait tout de même
beaucoup d'anarchistes présents et
c'était clairement un mouvement
anti-partie et anti-institutionnel et
sclé les normes français Clélia et en ce
sens on peut dire qu'il était
anarchisant
au matin malgré le fait que la réinity
n'a jamais autant mérité son surnom
l'ambiance est joyeuse est active on
plaisante on chante on interpelle des
participants qui seront à la conférence
on pousse aussi un peu pour essayer
d'entrer
les autorités qui avaient sous-estimé
l'ampleur de la mobilisation prennent
peur on appelle l'armée en renfort et la
garde nationale intervient ce que
l'histoire populaire a retenu sous le
nom de bataille comment
car pour répondre aux violences
policières et défendre le cortège un
petit groupe de manifestants a décidé de
répliquer
soudain un black bloc s'est formé
là il y a quelque chose qui fait
intégralement partie aujourd'hui de de
l'identité du mouvement cette
composante des Black Blocs et que nous
ne connaissions pas en tout cas en
Europe en Europe occidentale et donc on
a que nous avons vu surgir et qui alors
doudou vient-elle
le Black Bloc vient d'Allemagne de
l'Ouest
dans les années 70 il y avait les
autonomes certains se disaient
anarchiste d'autres se réclamaient
d'aucun parti et se disait juste
autonome
en portant le casque le masque et on se
protégeant contre les violences
policières et les identification
il faut dire qu'à l'époque en Allemagne
de l'Ouest la répression était très dure
il est antiterroriste
qui désigne une stratégie et non des
individus existait déjà depuis longtemps
c'est bien ici et ce jour-là qu'il se
fait connaître au monde
pendant plusieurs heures devant les
caméras des premières chaînes d'infos en
continu les révolutionnaires qu'il
adoptent assument la confrontation et
revendique l'usage de la violence
violence ça veut dire attention pas
contre les personnes ça veut dire contre
les choses c'est qu'il se cassent c'est
quand même des vitrines par exemple ou
des ou des caissiers automatiques c'est
une violence qui est très largement
symbolique qui est pas du tout une
violence physique directe sur des sur
des sur des personnes qui bien souvent
alors consistant des affrontements avec
la police mais pas pas disons dans une
violence extrême du tout qui consiste
dans la destruction éventuellement
symbolique de la propriété casser des
banques etc loin notre chaotique et des
ordonnées l'action du Black Bloc est en
effet raisonnée et réfléchi et si sur
son passage les vitrines volent en éclat
ce n'est pas seulement pour exprimer la
colère piller ou jouir du plaisir de
casser pour casser les cils ne sont
jamais prises au hasard c'est pour
montrer qu'il est possible d'attaquer
les succursales du capitalisme et avec
ce spectacle d'une violence très élégée
les caméras
coup double en quelque sorte à l'heure
du tout médiatique ou une image
sensationnelle vaut mieux parfois que de
longs discours ce recours inégocique à
la violence est en effet une propagande
à la fois par le fait et par l'image
[Musique]
il considère qu'il faut aller lutter
contre le capitalisme et cette pour
lutter contre les capitalistes qu'ils
utilisent ces techniques donc c'est
facile à lire les banques c'est les
banques c'est le fric c'est le
capitalisme financier actuel donc on
attaque les banques même si on ne fait
que gratiner sa surface mais au moins ça
attire l'attention de tout le monde et
seul la propagande gouvernementale fait
semblant de ne pas comprendre pour qu'on
attaque les banques tout le monde
comprend pourquoi on attaque les banques
[Musique]
à propagande de propagande et demi les
chaînes d'infos en continu diffusant en
boucle les images
mais assiettes on a beau déclaré l'état
d'urgence imposer le couvre-feu et
donner l'autorisation de tirer sur les
semoir le trouble le pouvoir a perdu
l'initiative on préfère interrompre le
sommet grâce à la mobilisation et à
l'action inattendue du Black Bloc la
bataille de Seattle est gagné
[Musique]
étonnamment ça a été un succès
on a vu qu'il était possible de faire
reculer le pouvoir et que l'autorité ne
pouvait pas se maintenir avec seulement
la police dans la rue l'autorité était
sapée parce que c'est une question de
foi juste une question de fois
il y a eu de telles manifestations
partout dans le monde à gêne Naples
Québec
partout les gens étaient en conflit avec
l'autorité
dans les années suivantes sur tous les
continents l'ombre du Black Bloc plan
sur les grands sommets qui se claquent
mieux et se barrica
il faut dire qu'à la suite de Seattle
son nombre n'a cessé de grandir sa
présence devient de plus en plus massive
dans les manifestations son action
rapide et efficace et ces images
toujours plus fascinantes le phénomène
est tel qu'en 2012 les métiers devient
le personnage de l'année de Time
Magazine
comme à la fin du 19e siècle dans les
cercles du pouvoir on parla nouveau
d'une internationale noire et l'on met
tout en oeuvre pour que seat elle ne
puisse plus se reproduire
on s'est servi de Seattle pour justifier
des recherches dans le domaine des
nouvelles armes aux États-Unis par
exemple il y a eu des recherches sur des
armes non létales comme ils disent tes
ultrasons des lasers tout ce qui
pourrait être utilisé dans des
manifestations contre les manifestants
et on a commencé à voir la police se
comporter comme une armée
les forces de l'ordre se sont en quelque
sorte militarisées un peu partout
ce nouvel arsenal de maintien de l'ordre
de pacification est aussitôt mise à
contribution dans toutes les grandes
manifestations avec ces armes non
létales on les borne mutilés
occasionnellement ont tue comme c'est
d'arriver en France avec rémicheresse
qui me soufflait par une grenade pour en
avoir pas voulu que l'on détruit un
écosystème
mais quand on perd le contrôle on
n'hésite pas à ressortir les armes les
vrais comment
c'est un enfant de 15 ans qui
participait à une manifestation est
assassinée par la police comme à Oracle
ou le journaliste anarchiste Brad will
qui filmait la révolte des professeurs
et tués par un sniper sous l'oeil de sa
caméra
un jeune libertaire de 22 ans est abattu
d'une balle dans la tête et pour se
dégager la jeep des carabines par ses
repas sur son corps
[Musique]
dès la fin de la décennie de nombreux
libertaires commencent à remettre en
question la stratégie du Black Bloc
n'est-elle pas devenu trop systématique
et donc prévisible au point de se
retourner parfois contre les
manifestants eux-mêmes après 10 ans
d'affrontement il est urgent d'imaginer
de nouvelles formes de lutte
[Musique]
depuis quelques années un nouveau monde
est né internet il faut dire que grâce à
la révolution numérique et aux facilités
d'échanges informatiques qu'elle induit
on a assisté à une augmentation sans
précédent dans l'histoire des flux
financiers
ce nouvel eldorado tourne les têtes des
multinationales et des grands organismes
bancaires qui misent de plus en plus
gros sans aucun contrôle le bulle
financière se crée qui explose en 2008
symbolisée par la chute de les mains
Brothers on assiste à la banque la plus
importante de toute l'histoire pour la
première fois depuis la crise de 1929 en
Occident des millions de personnes sont
jetées à la rue du jour au lendemain et
des pays entiers sont ruinés
si des révoltesaient par son lieu c'est
à l'automne 2011 au travers d'une
mobilisation internationale que de
manière inattendue et sans toujours dire
leur nom les anarchistes vont à nouveau
faire parler de avec le mouvement
occupé
c'est pour cela que ça a commencé à Wall
Street parce que Wall Street avait ruiné
l'économie mondiale avec des fraudes
massive pour lesquelles personnes ne
sera jamais condamnée
ce qui montre d'ailleurs la totale un
efficacité des états quand il s'agit de
contrôler le capitalisme international
aucune action sérieuse n'a été prise en
ce qui concerne les responsables de ces
gigantesques dévastations économiques
pour lesquelles des pays comme la Grèce
l'Espagne et ailleurs continuent de
payer
[Musique]
inspiré par les mouvements d'occupation
des places lors des printemps arabes et
du mouvement des Indignés en Espagne en
organisant un gigantesque bein au pied
du temple de la finance internationale
occupée
rassemblement de protestations et
création d'une Zone Autonome temporaire
[Musique]
le mouvement occupa et Wall Street qui
n'est pas un mouvement anarchiste à
proprement parler
et très fortement influencé par des
anarchistes d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'anarchistes ont mis en place
l'architecture de ce mouvement
qui a beaucoup écrit sur l'anthropologie
[Musique]
Tom Morello le guitariste de Rage
Against The Machine qui est aussi un
militant très actif des JW le grand
syndicat anarchiste nord-américain où
l'éternel ski qui vient y faire des
conférences mais si toutes les tendances
de l'anarchisme se retrouve bien ici et
que toutes ces tactique sont déployées
la mobilisation a aussi la particularité
d'agréger de nombreuses personnalités
qui n'appartiennent pas à son mouvement
libertaire mais doivent se positionner
en fonction de lui
car ce n'est pas le moindre des
paradoxes de l'anarchisme au moment où
ces pensées et ses pratiques se
généralisent que de se fondre et de
disparaître dans le mouvement
il s'agit d'idées et d'expériences qui
doivent avoir un sens pour nos vies et
qui puisse apport er à nos questions
le problème pour l'anarchisme n'est pas
de se faire connaître mais de nous
offrir une sorte de caisse à outils pour
les problèmes de la vie quotidienne
non les anarchistes ne se battent pas
pour un mandatarchiste heureusement
il se battent pour un monde libre et la
différence est cruciale en venant des
quatre coins du monde pour filmer
l'événement les caméras des Chaînes
d'infos laissent voir non plus sur des
théâtres lointains ou au travers d'une
violence au spectaculaire mais dans des
scènes de la vie quotidienne et au coin
de la rue ce que pourrait être une vie
débarrasser des nombreuses formes de
domination et d'exploitation car pendant
plusieurs mois ici on médite on discute
on rêve on chante on aime on partage et
on s'éduque on abolit comme toujours les
prisons les polices l'argent et les
frontières on imagine ensemble d'autres
mondes possibles et on essaie de les
réaliser maintenant
ils ont adopté des formes d'organisation
anarchistes
des petits groupes qui se coordonnent et
essaye de trouver le consensus au
travers de la démocratie directe
tout en se posant la question de ce
qu'il fallait faire pour que le
mouvement continue d'avancer
mais ces gens qui sont violents se
soient obstinent agir comme s'ils
étaient déjà libres des ranges dans
l'urgence des lois sont votées et la
répression Saba
[Musique]
Ies
comme toujours ont essayé de stopper le
mouvement occupé Wall Street
elles ont remis en vigueur les lois
contre le vagabondage et toutes ces lois
du XIXe siècle
et puis la police a cherché toutes les
excuses pour empêcher le mouvement
elle a parlé de trouble à l'ordre public
ou d'assembler illégale elle disait
qu'il y allait avoir des émeutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et au travers de ces grandes
mobilisations sont aujourd'hui à leur
nom les idées libertaires se diffusent
petit à petit et un train à nouveau
toute une partie du mouvement social
danse peu importe que vous soyez pour ou
contre l'anarchisme
à l'intérieur du mouvement
anticapitaliste vous devrez vous définir
en fonction de lui et vous devrez rendre
des comptes
votre pratique et vos organisations
sont-elles vraiment démocratiques
écoutez-vous chacun êtes-vous sensible
aux différences de genre homosexualité
et aux autres formes de diversité
en un mot êtes-vous plus humain
l'anarchisme ne s'enseigne pas ça ne
s'apprend pas dans les livres dans les
écoles dans les conférences l'anarchisme
ça se contagie c'est à dire qu'il y a
une transmission qui n'est pas de
l'ordre de la didactique le mouvement
libertaire profite au lieu aussi de
cette nouvelle popularisation de ces
idées et de ses pratiques comme la
prouvé le succès inattendu des aux
internationales de l'anarchisme qui
hurle Dieu en août 2012 en Suisse à
Saint-Imier et cette vigorneuve tord le
coup aux idées reçues sur la marche lui
que l'on avait voulu limiter à
l'Occident conquérant encore des
territoires comme ici le 1er mai 2019 en
Indonésie lui que l'on avait qualifié de
révolte petite bourgeoise touche à
nouveau les milieux les plus humbles lui
que l'on avait prétendu minoritaire
trouve un écho dans les nouvelles
générations qui se dit c'est un
gouvernable et lui que l'on avait si
souvent divaincu prouve malgré toute cet
effet qu'il est toujours vivant il y a
eu beaucoup de défaites dans l'histoire
du mouvement anarchiste des défaites
aussi grandes que les aspirations que
ces gens-là portaient mais une autre
façon de voir l'histoire l'anarchiste
qui me semble-t-il les plus
intéressantes plus juste aussi plus
respectueuse des faits c'est 80 c'est
grands moments qui sont des moments
d'échecs réels c'est-à-dire que c'est
vrai que la communauté c'est vrai que en
Espagne on l'a perdu il y a constamment
une victoire plus moins visible moins
spectaculaire mais qui sont présentes
partout mais tout de même remarquable
que ce que les anarchistes ont pensé
senties promus défendu depuis très très
longtemps et toujours du présent d'un
beaucoup d'éléments de notre culture
l'anarchisme a eu un rôle fondamental
dans le progrès des idées et dans le
progrès de l'humanité en général
mais l'anarchisme a toujours l'air
d'être là et de ne pas y être les
anarchistes semblent être partout et en
même temps on se demande tout le temps
mais où sont les anarchistes
l'anarchisme ne disparaîtra jamais parce
qu'il appartient à l'être humain chaque
fois que quelqu'un se demandera pourquoi
il faut obéir il y aura de l'anarchisme
[Musique]
loin de trachevé l'histoire de
l'anarchisme se poursuit donc
mais au terme de ces presque deux
siècles d'existence alors que des
figures plus récentes ont succédé aux
anciennes que ces courants se sont
multipliés que ces stratégies et cette
tactique se sont diversifiés et que de
nouveaux défis et de nouvelles menaces
sont apparues pour lui comme pour
l'humanité il semble que le message
d'espérance qu'elle porte et que
rappelait déjà Louise Michel dans sa
plaidoirie soit resté le même qu'au
premier jour
nous sommes à une époque
donc nous dirons quand même advienne que
pourra
que la liberté se fasse
que l'égalité se fasse
et nous serons heureux
est noir
notre drapeau rouge et noir
notre étoile jaune et noires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]